la situation sanitaire reste
préoccupante au mexique le pays vient de
dépasser la barre des 25 mille morts
liés aux kovy 19
avec plus de 200 mille cas confirmés
l'épidémie ne montre pas de signes
significatifs de ralentissement des
chiffres largement supérieur aux
premières estimations du ministère de la
santé
mais face à l'ampleur de la pandémie les
autorités mexicaines ont revu leurs
discours depuis février nous disons
préparons nous à une longue épidémie
dans ce contexte une langue épidémie
signifie qu'une fois que l'épidémie a
commencé le 28 février 2020 elle durera
au moins jusqu'en octobre 2020 selon les
prévisions mathématiques nous avons
réussi à avoir moins de cas par jour
surtout au plus fort de la crise nous
avons réussi à déplacer la date du pic
et à faire en sorte que personne ne soit
laissé sans surveillance
parce que l'hôpital est surchargé nous y
parvenons mais l'épidémie continue le
gouvernement est largement critiquée par
certains spécialistes pour sa
surveillance épidémiologique
en effet le mexique est le pays membres
de l' ocde qui effectue le moins de
tests de dépistage l'utilisation du
masque a également fait l'objet d'une
controverse entre les autorités et les
experts le président andres manuel lopez
obrador refusent de l'utiliser
publiquement un comportement qui
interroge alors que le ministre des
finances a annoncé ce jeudi être
contaminé par le coronavirus on vient de
me dire que j'ai été testé positif aux
copies 19 tu des symptômes très mineurs
à partir de ce moment je serai en
quarantaine et je continuerai de
travailler à domicile
une situation rendue d'autant plus
compliquée par le séisme qui a touché
mardi le sud du pays
les secousses ont été ressenties jusqu'à
mexico
par mesure de précaution le personnel
médical a évacué les hôpitaux de la
capitale
les patients atteints du coronavirus ont
pour le moment été maintenus à
l'isolément